foreign
let's go to Kelly next in New York City
New York Kelly how can we help
hi uh thank you very much for taking my
call you bet what's up calling because I
invested any startup company
and the amount that I had invested I
only had 25 left to be paid off
however I'm working two full-time jobs
to pay this bill
my sister had generously offered to pay
off the remaining balance
I don't think I should do that because I
could probably have this paid off by
January
so why not just pay it off and say thank
you sister for your generosity but I got
this one because I don't want to create
any resentment between us I don't want
to feel like I owe you something even if
you did it as a gift I'm going to have
this feeling on my heart this is on me
and I don't want that on my conscience I
love you too much to do that so I
appreciate it but I got this in a few
months it'll be gone
that's my line of thinking but she was
all about
um
which is why I'm calling she's all about
Dave Ramsey saying he just says pay it
off but I'm like I don't have that money
but you will in the next three months
how much is it
right now it's seven thousand
and what's your income
my income this both full-time job is 56.
yeah I I just I think I would say what
George said and if she keeps pressing
you on it I would say what is causing
you to keep aggressively offering to pay
my debt I don't need you to I don't want
you to I've said thanks what is it that
is driving you to keep doing this I
would kind of put it back on her
well she's already she told me that last
night what is it she told me that she's
very concerned about my house because
I'm starting to fall asleep
when I shouldn't be
okay
uh appreciate that but again you already
told us that you don't need it and you
don't think you should do it so you know
be a big girl and say thanks sis uh I'm
okay I'm just tired and maybe you go to
one full-time job and find a different
one that pays you as well as both do and
that's an option speed everything up a
little bit it doesn't have to crush you
and if it takes a few months longer
that's okay
do it at your pace but with
intentionality there's something in your
gut that is telling you not to take the
money from CIS you need to honor that I
would trust your gut on this one thank
you so much for the call you got this
hang in there get some rest this is the
Ramsey Show